[Applause]
well guys it's snowing October 31st here
I am in a onesie looking thick as hell
coming back from a company
dinner what have I done what have I
done hey everyone and welcome back to
the channel I hope you enjoyed the video
of me drunk and in my onesie obviously
that's why I wasn't able to record the
other night uh although it would have
been a lot of fun with me in that mental
state anyways I hope uh my pain is enter
in to you all you're all going to
benefit from it anyways because as a
result of my seasonal depression I'll
probably make more YouTube videos with
that being said we've got two more in
the systems design Series so let's
finish off the first of those two okay
let's get started so today we're going
to be talking about realtime updates and
the gist of a real-time update is that
basically so far you know we're all
familiar with HTTP requests right which
is that we have some client and it can
communicate with a server by sending it
some type of data but when it comes to
it unless the client specifically asks
for some data how can we make sure that
the client is able to just receive data
while basically always being on standby
to do so this is relevant in things like
messaging apps stock trading platforms
notification Services basically we don't
want to have to make the client ask all
the time it would be a lot better if the
server could just go ahead and push data
right to it well why don't we want the
client asking all the time well let's
discuss that quickly because the first
option that we could technically do to
achieve this type of thing is going to
be polling where every few seconds
basically the client which could be my
mobile device is going to go ahead and
request an update from a server so you
know every 4 seconds un repeat forever
you
know we are going to request from the
server and what's going to happen is
that this thing is going to get
overloaded and that's bad because now
we're wasting a ton of resources on both
our client and our server sending all of
these requests when the majority of them
are probably just going to come back
with no new information and so again
that's not great to give an analogy for
this type of thing think about it like
this you went on a date with a girl
she's ghosting you every 2 minutes you
keep checking your phone to see if uh
she's finally responded obviously she
hasn't we've all lived this out and uh
now you've wasted all your time and
energy trying and your phone battery is
dying too so let's move on to some
smarter things that we can actually do
in order to achieve this goal so the
first thing that we're going to be
talking about is long polling so long
polling is a a little bit different than
polling it might be named after my
phallic region but assuming it's not the
general gist is that it's very similar
to a poll request except if there's no
data present the server will actually
basically keep track of the fact that
there is a long pole request that is
active and we'll hold on to it until
data is actually available so a couple
of key things about long polling for
starters this is unid directional right
the client is basically reaching out to
the server and then the server passes it
data back you can't like also pass data
back to the server via a long poll on
some sort of consistent interval
basically it's just one long poll
returns some amount of data and then
it's closed out so upon completion we
need to create another and we'll discuss
the pros and cons of that in a second
but basically it would look like this
long poll
request you know maybe we'll wait 5
seconds until some data comes in and
then we'll finally
respond and then when we do what we
would have to do is say okay we're done
with this guy now time to start another
long
poll and now the cycle begins a new so
this can be like I mentioned potentially
good and a bad thing that you basically
have to restart these connections all
the time for starters uh it's kind of
expensive right because every single
time that we initiate a long poll we
have to send over a bunch of headers
they get involved in HTTP requests uh
additionally just you know creating uh
connections on the server is expensive
we need to allocate a port things like
that um and then additionally uh there
are a couple of good things with this uh
the first is that long polling is just
generally well supported it's an older
technology it's supported by all
browsers you don't really have to worry
about that but also generally speaking
let's say as opposed to something like a
persistent connection let's say you know
data is only coming in every 20 minutes
or so it would be good that you know we
can only submit very few long polls
relative to holding a persistent
connection and wasting a bunch of
resources but we'll talk about that more
in a second so that is going to bring us
to option two which is going to be
websockets so websockets keep in mind
are different than web hooks if you've
heard of that web hooks are just like a
a call back on HTTP requests but
basically the idea is that unlike long
polling first of all websockets are
bidirectional right so that means that
both the client can communicate to the
server and the server can actually
communicate back to the client via a
websocket and additionally unlike long
polling they are also persistent so as
you can see right here we've got these
two-sided arrows on the bottom of our
screen and they are basically going to
stay alive the entire time that those
two are connected you don't basically
have to tear them down and bring them
back up all of the time and so that's
really good because it means that you
know basically you send over some
headers or some metadata on your
original websocket connection but after
that all data being sent over that
websocket doesn't require any extra
metadata and that of course is going to
make it a little bit faster to send
those packets over the network that
being said like I mentioned before uh it
is the case that you know let's say
we've got all three of these connections
right here and this guy is only sending
data every 5 minutes well it means
basically now that we are persisting
this connection between all three of
these devices and the server that entire
time and that can just waste a bunch of
resources there's no reason to
necessarily persist these connections if
we're very rarely sending information
additionally it is worth noting that if
the connection goes down right you know
if this guy gets broken for some reason
we have some sort of network partition
then websockets is not going to
reestablish that for us we're going to
have to add some extra client side logic
to put it back together and the only
reason I mention that now is because in
option three this is actually fixed for
us in server sent events which is going
to be our third potential Choice one
thing to note is that like websockets
the connection is persistent but it also
reconnects automatically for you that's
technology built into service and events
which which is kind of nice uh unlike
websockets and similar to Long polling
uh this is a unidirectional connection
so it's only going to be from server to
client that's where the data is being
passed if you wanted to go and pass data
from the client to the server you would
have to do that just via a normal HTTP
request or something like that and so of
course with all of these Technologies
there are some pros and cons Associated
which we will now talk about so
basically the big Pro of a server sent
event is that similar to websockets due
to the nature of a persistent connection
there is less overhead in sending data
and additionally just actually making
more connections which is very nice of
course it has the same cons of
websockets in the sense that well now we
can waste resources if this connection
is largely inactive but the big final
point that I want to focus upon with
server andent events is this piece of
actually reestablishing connections for
you now you may think oh that's super
convenient you don't have to write this
yourself you could potentially screw it
up but is it always a good thing so now
let's think about a hypothetical
situation which I will call the
Thundering Herd problem and no I am not
referring to my farts so the first thing
is Imagine we've got like these three
clients over here and at Time Zero
client one is going to connect right
that's going to establish the server
sent event and I should actually just
have the arrow going the other direction
because that's the way service ENT
events are going so time
zero and then then we're going to make
another one at time five now client two
is connecting and then client three is
going to connect at time 10 so let's
imagine now that these guys have all
connected and they're all getting data
from the server but all of a sudden you
know who knows I come along and dump
some water on here and then bang this
guy goes down at time
12 and then it's going to come back up
at time
15 so now time 15 we're good again so
keep in mind that all of these
connections were broken in that meantime
and they're now all going to try and
reconnect and they're going to do so at
time
15 now if there are only three devices
in reality this probably isn't a very
big deal however uh in an actual big
scalable web application you might have
hundreds of these clients and so all of
them connecting to this server at the
same time well that can add a bunch of
extra load and now this thing is going
to go back down again and it's not going
to be able to come back up and that's
known as the Thundering Herd so because
of the nature of all of these
connections trying to reestablish
themselves we can overload that server
it can go back down and that would be a
big problem so how could we fix
something like this well actually if
you've watched this entire series which
would be awesome then you've seen the
episode I made on raft uh and one of the
things basically that raft does in order
to avoid something like a Thundering
Herd problem when it comes to leader
elections is basically the timeout of
trying to reconnect or trying to start a
new leader elction ction actually has a
random Jitter right so you know let's
say we pick a random number between 0
and 5 Seconds when we think that the
server is back up and then we try and
reconnect so rather than you know
restarting everything at time 15 maybe
this guy restarts at time 18 this guy
restarts at time 16 and this guy
restarts at time 19 and then that way
you know the connections are actually
spread out a little bit we're more
likely to not overload the server which
would be a good thing I'm not not sure
this is actually something that
practically you'll have to experience
too much but it is something worth
considering when you think to yourself
oh it's so good that we just
automatically reconnect to a
server so let's quickly talk about a
conclusion here I'm not actually going
to go into all three of the Technologies
and say hey one thing is just like
clearly better than the other but there
are certain traits of each type of
technology and each of those traits has
its own pros and cons so the two that
I'm going to be focusing on for this
conclusion are persistent connections
and automatic reconnection
so keep in mind that if you do have a
persistent connection as is the case
with
websockets and also service and events
basically what that means is it should
in theory be pretty fast you're not
sending a ton of headers over the
network and additionally you're not
establishing a ton of connections that
being said if it is the case that you're
not sending that much data from your
server to your client or more so you're
not sending data that frequently then
you could just be wasting resources and
well frankly if we can avoid that it
would be a thing the other thing I want
to be talking about is automatic
reconnects which while convenient if
we're not careful about them can cause a
Thundering Herd as we just described in
the last image well guys I hope this one
helps I hope you have a great day and
I'm looking forward to finishing up the
series and doing some real problems